♪ ♪
>> Jesse: MICKEY MOUSE IS AT
IT AGAIN.
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO,
DISNEY-OWNED
"NATIONAL GEOGRAPHIC" GAVE US A
DOCUMENTARY "FAUCI," A PUFF
PIECE MEANT TO RESURRECT THE
CAREER OF A GUY WHO HAS BEEN
WRONG ABOUT PRETTY MUCH
EVERYTHING.
NOW AT DISNEY-OWNED HULU HAS
ANOTHER SUPER VILLAIN THERE
TRYING TO FIT INTO THE LAST
SUPPER, CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
AUTHOR OF THE DIRTY AND VERY
DISCREDITED DOSSIER.
THE FORMER SPY SAT DOWN WITH
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS FOR A NEW
DOCUMENTARY SERIES AND IS BEING
TREATED AS A HERO FOR TAKING ON
TRUMP AND PUTIN.
>> HE'S A HERO, A TRADER.
>> CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS A GUY
WHO PICKED A FIGHT WITH TWO
PRESIDENTS: DONALD TRUMP AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AND HE HAS LIVED TO TELL THE
TALE.
>> WHEN YOU BRING INFORMATION TO
THE FBI IN 2016, WERE YOU ACTING
AS A PATRIOT OR PAID PRIVATE
INTELLIGENCE?
I MEAN, THIS IS THE STUFF OF
MOVIES.
>> Jesse: I WONDER WHOSE
REPUTATION THEY ARE GOING TO TRY
TO REPAIR NEXT, ANDREW CUOMO,
BILL COSBY, O.J.?
[LAUGHS]
LES ASKED CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS DISNEY-OWNED, THEY HATE
TRUMP, STEPHANOPOULOS, A CLINTON
HACK AT ABC, IN OUR REALITY, A
TOTAL SCOUNDREL.
>> JESSE, I WOULD SAY THIS, THIS
IS FAR BEYOND WHAT I WOULD
EXPECT THEM TO GO BECAUSE YOU DO
A LITTLE RESEARCH, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT STEPHANOPOULOS DID, BUT IN
OUR INVESTIGATION WE DID, WE
FOUND STEELE PROBABLY DIDN'T
EVEN WRITE THESE DOSSIERS COVER
NUMBER ONE, BECAUSE THERE WAS A
SET OF PREDOSSIERS THAT
ESSENTIALLY HAD SOME OF THE SAME
STORIES.
NOW, DID STEELE DEVELOP THE
INFAMOUS PEEPE TAPE THAT IS IN
THE PROMO, THAT IS OUTLANDISH?
WE DON'T KNOW IF THEY ARE GOING
TO ASK THE RIGHT QUESTIONS OR
NOT, BUT WHEN WE TRIED TO REACH
OUT TO STEELE'S LAWYERS -- I SAY
WE, REPUBLICANS ON THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, WHEN WE
WERE DOING THE INVESTIGATION,
STILL THE ONLY REAL
INVESTIGATION, WE ARE ALL
WAITING ON A DURHAM, HE DID NOT
WANT TO TALK.
THE FACT HE IS NOT TALKING AND
TAKING CREDIT FOR SOMETHING THAT
HAS BEEN COMPLETELY DISCREDITED
AND LAUGHED AT, THAT ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THE INTELLIGENCE WORLD
THAT WERE LOOKING AT THIS IN
2016 SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT THIS
WAS JUST A FRAUD, IT DID NOT
EVEN LOOK LIKE A REAL
INTELLIGENCE REPORT.
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO DISNEY,
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO HULU,
IT'S AN EMBARRASSMENT TO BRITISH
GOVERNMENT AND MI6 IF THIS GUY
EVER WORKED FOR THEM, AND
LOOKED, THERE IS PROBABLY MORE
TO COME.
I'M SURE IT WILL BE QUITE A
COMICAL, ENTERTAINING MOVIE.
>> Jesse: I DON'T THINK THEY
ARE EMBARRASSED AT ALL.
FOR THEM, THIS IS LEGACY REPAIR.
>> SURE.
>> Jesse: THIS IS PUTTING A
HISTORICAL RECORD DOWN,
DIGITALLY, TO COVER UP ALL THE
DIRTY DEEDS THAT THESE GUYS DID.
SO, YOU KNOW, 50 YEARS, 75
YEARS, YOU LOOK BACK, WHO WAS
CHRISTOPHER STEELE?
CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE A GOOD GUY.
HE IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE A GUY
THAT TOOK ON TRUMP, NOT THE REAL
DIRTBAG THAT HE ACTUALLY IS, AND
WHEN YOU HAVE THE POWER OF HULU,
DISNEY BACKING, A POLISHED
STEPHANOPOULOS SITTING THERE
STROKING HIMSELF, IT LEGITIMIZES
SOMEONE LIKE THIS, WHO IN ANY
SANE WORLD WOULD BE SEEN AS ONE
OF THE DIRTIEST INTERNATIONAL
SCOUNDRELS IN THE LAST, YOU
KNOW, COUPLE DECADES,
POLITICALLY.
SPEAKING OF SCOUNDRELS, I'M GLAD
I REFERENCED THAT, McCABE,
YOUR GOOD BUDDY OVER AT THE DOJ,
REMEMBER HE GOT FIRED FOR LYING
AND LEAKING.
NOT ANYMORE, HE'S GOING TO GET
HIS PENSION BACK, THE BIDEN
DOJ -- HE'S GOING TO GET
CUFFLINKS BACK, AND THEY ARE
GOING TO SCRUB ANY MENTION HE
WAS FIRED FROM THE FBI.
>> YEAH, LOOK, THIS IS WHAT WE
EXPECT FROM BIDEN'S DOJ.
I THINK IT WAS A GIVEN THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO DO THIS.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN, TO YOUR
POINT, DIDN'T HE CAN DO WHAT
THEY WANT TO DO.
THE BIDEN DOJ CAN LET PEOPLE OFF
IF THEY LIKE.
DURHAM IS STILL OUT THERE, AND A
LOT OF THE FUTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY REALLY DEPENDS -- THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI TO HAVE ANY SUPPORT AMONGST
CONSERVATIVES OR HALF OF THIS
COUNTRY, IT'S GOING TO REALLY
DEPENDS ON WHO DURHAM INVITES,
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT A LOT
OF US ARE WAITING FOR.
IT APPEARS LIKE HE IS MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION, AND
HOPEFULLY HE GETS TO FINISH HIS
INVESTIGATION SO WE CAN GET
CLOSURE FOR THIS.
I AGREE WITH YOU, THAT IS PART
OF WHERE WE ARE IN THIS WORLD
RIGHT NOW.
YOU GOT BASICALLY REALITY, THEN
AN ALTERNATIVE REALITY THAT IS
CREATED BY THE LEFT, AND IT IS
WHAT WE DEAL WITH EVERY DAY.
>> Jesse: DURHAM BETTER HURRY
UP, A LOT OF PRESSURE ON THAT
GUY.
I'M SO HAPPY FOR McCABE TO GET
HIS CUFFLINKS BACK.
THEY MUST BE VER